yeah welcome to this video five minute
game let's go deform and see what
happens you 6mm up lady three other the
colored sister Maya I looked at this
quite some time ago and some ideas are
liked it's a very it's very easy to play
set up for white let's see okay place it
simple and just taking only form with
this now I'm should be around a
comfortable position for white it's not
not terrible for black by any means but
then it's certainly am comfortable to
play so maybe queen e to take first
let's break when you to first yeah white
has an easy development IAM play rook e1
bishop god aha this is some surprising
move so as I play a Queenie for next and
attack you poach both 87 and c 6-r
interesting to see how I am avoids
material losses now yeah I can just take
the six now it can take here and then
stare some brilliant trick violets let's
check this again Quincy 623 create and
then there's Queen takes f1 now or
bishop a6 this kind of stuff
this is weird okay maybe I should play
Bishop h6 first to have this covered and
check again it's Queen c6 queen bee
three who yeah Bishop 860 so weird I
play this first what should you do the
rook is also hanging he can um player
should be seven but then it's then it's
expected i can just take the exchange
okay so how do i will continue here
trying to make my technical task as easy
as possible Queen F form and then Bishop
b4 maybe hmm the other should be to
better anyway get out of this diagonal
know if we should befall ready yet this
intends to play 26 maybe fear if he
allows this okay not sure what the
smoothest doing but okay I wanted to
play this anyway the bishop must be good
only form okay now so now he needs to
exchange queens I guess Queenie 827 is
also not much fun or Quincy seven
hmm so Quincy 7 on 27 27 they can play
quinta piayed Quincy 7 if would play a
rugby I'd probably then I have root d7
also that doesn't look nice doesn't look
nice for black at all maybe ask ambition
Diego some some weird move I Quincy's
heaven you cannot click another white
the Queen's right at all complete
nonsense here okay so trade the Queen
now yeah come on it's an exchange after
all and now look this seminar property 7
rook to d1 looks like very a good
control so Roxy seven now attacking the
knight and well if we exchanged yeah
probably ISS something something better
now it doesn't really matter we exchange
them i get rid of his bishops then it
should be fairly easy now now i am even
double attacking e5 and b5 so i wouldn't
be five porn
gads this must be rather easy now black
resigned yeah yeah I will tie will
manage in one minute so just push the
sea porn basically i need the King King
may be king f 1 e 2 and then push the
sea point home all the way yeah ok this
was rather easy win but this kind of
idea as of course well worth remembering
it will be cautious each seven and c6 is
often critical for for double attacks
yeah thanks for watching